[Music]  medic  oh Jesus  is a  Beth we should go  millions of dollars worth of cocaine  fell from the sky this morning in  Knoxville Tennessee there's more this  out there they dumped it somewhere I'm  looking for my daughter's first is a  dangerous place Henry check it out  something got into it a deer Maybe  a lot of cocaine was lost I need you to  go and get it  no don't eat that don't eat that let's  see what kind of effect that has  [Music]  cocaine  [Music]  cocaine  a bear it was far hey that's  inappropriate  you're safe Bears can't climb trees of  course they can  [Music]  oh [ __ ]  [Music]  it kind of seems like the thing that  stays with a man forever  apex predator  high on cocaine  thought of it's mine  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]